Would we be allowed to use cratum for pain management?
We really do not love the idea of using ibuprofitantilinol and just try to find something more natural.
Well, first of all, I would say, cratum is not natural, so that does not fall into the natural realm.
My issues with cratum, I have a lot of issues with cratum.
The biggest issue with cratum is that it's not natural and the sources of cratum
are going to be very dirty. By that, I mean, you could get cratum laced with all sorts of things.
I personally had, we had an employee a number of years ago who was dating a gentleman who was
in his 50s, I think, and he was rushed to the hospital one morning because he had taken cratum
that he had purchased somewhere. He thought it was very natural person and he was very careful
on his sources too. I don't know what he was taking cratum for, but it almost killed him.
He was in here when the ER and it was laced with something.
It just to go and take a product that could be laced with ventral or something like that,
I think it's just highly inappropriate. It would be completely inappropriate for me to recommend
that. I am very much against doing something like that. It's, you know, I just go down to the street
quarter, a busy intersection and find out somebody selling drugs because that's about what you're
going to get. We know somebody that worked at an institute for helping people with drug rehabilitation
and that was a major drug that people were addicted to. I would personally, as much as I would
against taking drugs, I would rather use a drug that is more monitored and
out than something like cratum. So, I would say don't.